how could a full-time
auburn pd officer commit all the crimes
he was doing
across all northern california i was
like there's just no way you know that
he wouldn't have the time
[Music]
howard doss
what's happening sean man uh
i'm excited
and yet sad it's what they call that
what they call bittersweet i believe
about this episode um and our guest
doesn't even know this yet so
uh we'll introduce him here in a moment
but we have been at this cocktails and
cocktails thing for
a long time yeah and it was something
that started on a car ride that we had
during the covet days when you were
doing nursing up in the new york city
area uh at the heyday of covid and when
you so kindly flew up and rode back with
me i did i flew up rode back with you so
we had a lot of time together a lot of
bullshit in the car and
um basically became professional
bootleggers we picked up a lot of
bourbon along the way in kentucky
allegedly allegedly any any atf people
allegedly chase a x cop with liquor
rather than a gun toter that's fine yeah
but um so
uh we came up with the idea cocktails
and cocktails got on board with the long
crime network
and uh this is our very last episode
that we're doing
um and reason being that we're doing it
i'll let you give your spiel for it well
you know you
started working and i've started working
and unfortunately we work on different
ends of the united states i'm going to
be in oregon you are and you're going to
be aware what's that small town i'm in
little place called new york
city so we can't be together as much
that's correct so we are sad about that
i can see you are i am man it's this hey
this has been fun it's been a learning
experience it's been fun very very
thankful uh that we were able just a
couple dudes from oklahoma to pull this
thing together and
have success with it and everybody that
tuned in and listening well we're really
good at the cocktails part that's what
really that won't change
speaking of that yep we're gonna drink a
cocktail but first we're gonna talk
about
we've got a super guest today so we did
comic or not comic con crime con grime
gun
and uh
we
were kind of introduced to the crime
genre there
and
we didn't have the pleasure of meeting
our guest but we had the pleasure of
meeting about oh i don't know 20 000 of
his fans
that were there
just eagerly waiting for him his only
only fans yeah it was kind of like only
fans but he was it was like he was the
beatles of crime con very much so so
we've got uh paul holes with us today
sir
hey how you guys doing
doing well paul thank you so much so
like i said sorry to drop a little bomb
on you and no pressure here we're gonna
see how you hold up uh honestly couldn't
think of a better guess to have with our
for our final one so
all the way from quincy smith being
episode one uh to paul holes for our
final episode can't everything in
between has been fantastic so we're glad
you're here yeah absolutely
i'm absolutely honored that you guys are
having me as your last guest i'm
saddened that uh you guys are continuing
you know but uh hopefully uh we'll all
stay in touch once all is said and done
after this episode absolutely
hey what's on his shelf back behind him
besides a book that said unmasked my
life solving america's cold case paul
holds what's next to that
well that's the most important part and
that's that's suburban i heard you guys
talked about your little tour through
through kentucky you know and i wonder
how much of that bourbon you actually
purchased versus just kind of took off
with
well if there was a good investigator
out there he could probably solve that
crime pretty quick yeah we need to know
what kentucky's extra dick actually
extradition
uh extradition
would you call me gonna extradite you
you extra dick yeah they're uh what
they're what they're doing you know
multi-states outside the states or
whatever all right but can we drink some
bourbon we are so so paul we've got a
old
big boy here of uh well
that's an old one too yeah
they don't even make it that big anymore
so cheers welcome to our show sir and
that's courtesy of jason sales who's not
here with us
okay so i know a little bit of your
background i know that
you share a couple of things in common
with both of us the one thing you share
in common with me is that you were a
military brat your dad was in the air
force so you moved around so you share
that with me
and the other part is he
my dad was in the military for 32 years
and my mom was in for 20. howard i bet
they trump yours but he shares that with
me too go ahead i was going to get to
you about the part that he uh landed out
in vacaville okay are you from are you
were you at travis air force base yeah
my dad was stationed at travis i see
there you go yeah i went to high school
at the high you know abandoned high
school right outside of travis and i
lifeguarded for i think what four years
at the travis air force base pools well
i graduated from fairfield high
and
i swear to god yeah i lived uh
actually our house was in sassoon but
you know of course travis air force base
is where the commissary was and we went
grocery shopping and all that stuff wow
what a small world yeah i lived when we
first moved out there in the eighth
grade i i went to uh sullivan middle
school in fairfield and i was living in
a rental right across the street from
fairfield high wow
man no so i lived okay well we're just
going to keep going and anyone doesn't
give a shit probably but
uh i lived on treasure island there in
san francisco yeah when it was you know
the naval base and in eighth grade my
parents didn't want me going to uh
vallejo high school in city of san
francisco so we moved out to fairfield i
went to eighth grade at grange
uh middle school yep grange and then uh
then fairfield high so the fairfield
falcons
wow
i don't know that but yeah i don't know
and it's made it up
i mean what dare i ask what year you
graduated high school uh 92 i graduated
in 92. oh okay so i was i was 86 so i
predate you it doesn't
lost pass but we were you know in the
same place uh
same mud so to speak wow what that's
pretty that's pretty awesome honestly
yeah it's so tough okay so with that
said he
go ahead and tell us your path into law
enforcement you didn't initially get
into
law enforcement through the normal
channels like i've always dreamed of
being a police officer
yeah you know i
i ended up
you know
when i was a kid i became fascinated
with this old tv show called quincy you
know he was a forensic pathologist
uh little did i know that forensic
pathologists or they don't go to crime
scenes they don't investigate cases you
know they're stuck in the morgue cutting
up bodies but i
didn't know that so i thought well i
want to become a forensic pathologist
and had aspirations on going to medical
school i
ended up going to uc davis was pre-med
with biochem degree
and kind of
the the goals
derailed my grades so to speak so med
school was out of the question
uh but while at a job fair i ran across
uh an old time criminalist at a booth
and i'd never heard of criminalistics
but once i heard about how they used
science to solve crimes which was very
much in line with what the tv show
quincy was doing i was like sold
and so that's what i ended up pursuing
and i was initially hired as a civilian
forensic scientist
and then promoted up to a criminalist
position about three and a half years
into my career but my department was
weird we were the last department in the
uh
in california that required the
criminalist to go to the police academy
so i ended up going to the police
academy and becoming a deputy sheriff
criminalist
and i was assigned to
the crime lab doing crime scene
investigation i was assigned to the
serology unit doing abo testing and
enzyme testing and ultimately dna work
but i really gravitated towards the
investigative side and so as i
worked cases and then ultimately
promoted up through the ranks i took
advantage of having that sworn
peace officer power and uh decided you
know what i'm gonna do more than just
you know suck fluid from one little tube
to another doing dna analysis i'm gonna
go talk to people and try to solve cases
and and i gravitated towards the cold
case side
as well as the serial predator side and
i spent
for the most part uh 24 years of my
career
working as a forensic scientist and as a
cold case investigator and then
ultimately
you know the last few years i was with
contra costa county i had transferred
over to the district attorney's office
as a
bonafide cold case investigator and and
that's when i got the notoriety of uh
you know helping solve the golden state
killer case
wow so a little and i know it sounds
generic but you know i was just a little
criminal justice major
small state school
i'm familiar with uc davis you know
actually i saw nirvana at uc davis i was
gonna throw that out there i really did
it's big yeah back in like 9 80 90 maybe
or something
was it at the rec hall at uc davis yeah
you know yeah
i know exactly where that was at dude
that's a big flex i didn't know that
that was that was just before they
exploded right when they were kind of
just getting hit and hitting huge how
was the show it was amazing man so yeah
did you ever wear a uniform
you know i well when i was out in the
field for the the csi work i
wore a hand-me-down jumpsuit
uh you know of course you know i was
badged up i had the sidearm on um
and then after 9 11. i was now a
lieutenant level position and the
commander forced all of us on wednesdays
to wear a uniform throughout the day
so that was really the extent of my
uniform wearing with the sheriff's
office until i went over to the da's
office and then it was polo shirt you
know bdus and when i was out in the
field you know i had my sidearm on
did you ever write a citation
no no i know
my
my role was you know when it came to the
investigative side was really compiling
the physical evidence going after the
forensics talking to witnesses and when
i would get to a point where i thought i
had something significant on the case
and i'm pulling in resources and then as
a team we would pursue what i had
discovered
well we've probably had 40 probably 45
police officers on here right sure
and i think this is the first police
officer we probably have had that hasn't
wrote a citation of some sort
this is the first and the last for us
it was more of a formality i'm sure just
that the deputization uh type of deal
well paul let's talk about sorry go
ahead no i was just going to say in in
some ways it was uh but then
as i said as i progressed through my
career it turned out to be very
advantageous because
i closed my career out as an fbi task
force officer you know so not only am i
getting that training i had
federal level powers and resources to
apply to cases it was awesome hey and i
also know that means you have a certain
amount of overtime allotted to you
as a uh a cross-deputized agent
yes yes so yeah just so you don't know
in case you don't know that howard
whether you work a task force with if
you're a regular cop and you work with
atf or dea or fbi there's a certain
amount that the federal government's
allowed to pay these officers over time
throughout the year so it's a it's a
nice bump when you're if you know if
you're it's kind of like a i mean you're
gonna work you earn it i mean you're out
there working don't get me wrong
but it's just uh
i don't know it's a reward essentially
you're going to put in the hours and
you're going to get this extra overtime
okay so paul let's talk about obviously
the golden state killer as you mentioned
is kind of the one that you know
everybody knows about a couple other
cases i would love to hear about some
other guys that are sitting on death row
that you were involved with
um as well because i'm a firm believer
and people that commit heinous crimes
should get that justice i know
california system it might not happen
but at least they're sitting where they
need to where they need to be
um kind of i'll let you just you know
break down the golden state keller
situation you know when it started i
think what 76 or something like that and
how it led up to
your involvement and ultimately his
confession
sure you know uh
initially
the case as i knew it when i first
ran across it in 1994 was known as the
east area rapist case
and this was a serial rapist that
started uh off
up in sacramento in june of 1976
breaking into houses in the middle of
the night
tying up and sexually assaulting women
and eventually
after about 15 attacks the this east
area rapist started to purposely break
into houses
when there was a man present when there
was couples asleep in their bed
and in those situations you know he is
going into the couple's bedroom
he's standing at the foot of the bed or
in the doorway
he's waking them up and as soon as they
wake up he's shining a flashlight in
their eyes so they can't see a thing and
then through
uh you know clenched teeth
he's basically
hissing at them do what i say or i will
kill you i have a 357 or a 44 magnum i
will spatter your brains across the wall
if you don't do what i say and he'd put
the gun in the beam of the flashlight so
the couple could see that he did really
have a gun
then he would tie uh he would
throw bindings to the woman
and force her to tie her husband or
boyfriend up face down on the bed and
then once the man was secure he would go
and tie up the woman
then he'd go through the house and then
come back with
typically dishes or other types of
trinkets that he would stack on the back
of the man
and then would tell the man if i hear
these
she's dead or i'll kill everybody in the
house if there are kids in the house and
then you take the woman out to the
family room where he would sexually
assault the woman
um and this was a pretty standard m.o
there were some deviants but you know
for the rest of his series up until
uh basically mid
1979 after 50 attacks in northern
california he just disappeared
well it turns out
in october of 79 he goes down to santa
barbara which is southern california
just north of los angeles
and in this case it's a
standard east area rapist attack up up
the north but they don't know you know
they they don't never heard of east area
but they don't know his mo
but in once he separates the woman up
out in that case in santa barbara she
hears him pacing back and forth i'm
going to kill him this time i'm going to
kill him
she freaks out
he loses control of that particular case
and escapes two months later
he commits his first double well i
shouldn't say his first double homicide
but he commits a double homicide in
santa barbara
and then from that point on all the
cases that we know of attributed to the
golden state killer down in in southern
california were homicide cases he ended
up killing
you know starting in 1979 he killed 10
people across six cases down
there
so so did he
once he got down to santa barbara in
this other incident did every case going
forward that he was involved with he
killed or is that just at that was kind
of the breaking point after the 50
up north he then started
sometimes killing people
now he
from what we know all the cases that we
know of attributed to him from that
point on in southern california were
homicides there was no no cases that
were
aware of where he left the victims alive
after that first santa barbara case
where it just went sideways on him
so when he went from north to south was
he relocating there was did he move
there was this a just criminal tourism i
think is what they refer to it as what
was
did he just want a new hunting ground
what was what was that about
well you know
before the case was solved
we didn't know and the assumption was is
that the offender
was moving around the state and
committing crimes where he was living
when i was evaluating the geographic
profile up in northern california and
the the last phase that he had up in
northern california was my jurisdiction
the east bay san francisco bay area
and the original investigators assumed
that he had moved there but when i took
a look at the profile
he did not show the broad familiarity of
the region like he was showing up in
sacramento and so i formed the opinion
oh he never moved out of sacramento he's
literally just traveling around northern
california
and then with southern california
my thought was is it's possible he's
still just traveling around the state
and his home base continued to be out of
sacramento
i will tell you now that we've
identified the golden state killer as
joseph deangelo
we still don't know
entirely why he's in certain locations
at certain times he did move down to
southern california
for a period of time
but not the entire time you know for all
the homicides he wasn't down there the
entire time he was traveling back and
forth for some of those cases so he
truly was
uh very mobile when it came to you know
what his home base was what a strong
anchor point was versus where he was
committing these attacks
and for d'angelo uh
you said you got involved looking at
stuff in 1994
start these cases started in 1976 with
the rapes
and how long did they go on were they
still going on into the 90s when when
you got into looking at these or they
had just kind of they had stopped
sometime in the 80s right
yeah well you know
the the series as i knew it when i first
started the east area rapist series had
actually ended in 1979 he disappeared
off the face of the earth
uh what
part of what i thought was going to be
my claim to fame on the case is in 2001
using dna and and a telephonic level
investigation i was able to show that
the sarah rapist was this guy who was
down south killing people who they knew
as the original night stalker the last
known case down there which was an
irvine in orange county just south of
los angeles and that was may 5th 1986
where he bludgeoned little 19 year old
janelle cruz to death in her bed
we have no known
cases after 1986 attributed to d'angelo
but then along comes a new criminal
forensics
guy that's a little curious and finds a
file cabinet in the back
and starts digging through files right
so i assume this guy starts he started
his crime spree stopped his crime spree
and then thought okay i'm good
so how did you put all these pieces
together other than using the telephone
and the new technology of dna
well you know it was it was quite the
evolution in terms of as i worked the
case over years you know trying to get a
better
understanding of who this offender was
you know early on the original
investigators and i
you know felt that well he's probably a
young younger man the late teens to mid
20s
uh you know this you know
kind of this roving poor drug addicted
sex deviant that's just kind of
traveling across the countryside in part
based on what the living victims said to
the you know the investigators back in
the 1970s he would come in and say i'm
here for food and money wear your drugs
he would sometimes pretend to shake like
he had withdrawal symptoms
you know so there's there was a an
element of what i call verbal
or behavioral staging
in which the offender was trying to
portray himself as something he was not
you know it turns out while he's
pretending to be this drug addict he was
a full-time law enforcement officer you
know so he's she's def he's trying yeah
he's trying to he's trying to throw off
the investigators he had law enforcement
training he had investigative training
when it related to burglaries
um so he was a more sophisticated
offender and
when i
really zeroed in on one guy a railroad
worker i spent two years looking for
this guy because he dropped off the face
of the earth and finally
we found him and i eliminated him with
dna
was like i was devastated i thought how
could i be wrong i was sure it was him
and that's when i realized oh you know i
made him fit the evidence versus having
the evidence guide me
and that's when i rejiggered my thought
process and then i started evaluating
and reevaluating the information in the
case files
and that's when i started to see oh this
is a much more intelligent and
sophisticated offender than what i gave
him credit for at the beginning
and that gave me much better insight in
terms of how i should proceed and and
quite frankly there's a piece of
evidence this hand-drawn diagram that
i had numerous experts tell me it looks
like a developer trying to figure out
how to you know do a master plan lake
central community and i thought okay
this guy's in the real estate
development you know
contractor type world and focused in on
that but i was investigating some people
who were worth millions of dollars and i
was making some pretty good
circumstantial cases against these guys
only to eliminate them with dna
and then fundamentally
dna was what turned out to solve the
case and and it was just due to the new
technology when it came to the genetic
genealogy
all right well and paul we'll get to
that about how that kind of all came
together but just talk about when you
went back you know originally thinking
this was possibly a drug addict a poor
guy and then you know
you ultimately learned it wasn't one of
the things i read about that you did is
you actually even went out
uh i don't know if it was to every house
but you went out to numerous homes you
know we're talking years and years later
after these crimes were committed up
there to basically look at the houses
look at the neighborhood to kind of get
an idea
of why
these particular homes these victims
were chosen and from my understanding
again going back to what i read is you
were just talking about you formulated
you're like hey this guy
he's gonna blend in in here he's not
gonna be somebody that doesn't look like
they they don't belong here that
someone's gonna you know call the police
because hey there's a homeless looking
guy hanging out in our neighborhood no
well that's a actually
was spot on i went to every single crime
known crime scene location
from the east area right from the 1976
east area rapist phase through the
original night stalker phase and that
was so enlightening because he's not
attacking in poor areas you know the the
the areas that i would say would be the
most
yeah
kind of
common areas were solid middle class
areas you know the houses were nice
yards well kept you know decent cars and
the driveways are on the street
and then some of the areas where he's
attacking uh were i would say mid upper
to even upper-class neighborhoods most
notably
down in laguna niguel in orange county
the southernmost attack which was a
gated
you know
secure neighborhood right you know a few
blocks away from the beach houses were
worth a ton of money
and there's roving security guards or
security guards at the gate and i was
like how is this guy getting in here if
he's just driving a beater car and
looking like some you know homeless
zombie walking around
they would be calling the cops right
away and that told me well this guy
he blends in yeah you know so
that was part of you know as i evolved
and looked at the case that contributed
to
my understanding of him uh where now i'm
i'm elevating him up to somebody where
okay he's he's not somebody who stands
out as a vagabond he's somebody that can
blend into these nicer communities
okay so this came as a shack to me and i
i like to do some research but what i
really like to do is i like to hear the
story about this so you were using you
had a lot of people that you were trying
to fit like okay i got a square peg i'm
trying to put in this round hole i'm
doing this this goes on for years and
this is a case that
i mean stopped in the 80s and you're
still working on it in the early 2000s
right yeah and then you you meet a uh
a wonderful
uh investigative reporter
and she kind of sparks your interest and
just like i think everybody in the world
right now we're kind of a little
reluctant to talk to the media because
we don't know what their motives are uh
can you kind of share that with us sure
you know um
at a task force meeting law enforcement
task force meeting for this case
uh larry poole from orange county
sheriff's office had been in contact
with michelle mcnamara who was a true
crime blogger
and she was going to write an article
about this case that she recently
learned about and became fascinated with
which was our case east era rapist case
and he had asked the task force members
hey is it okay do we should we cooperate
with her and we you know did a round
table and we all agreed it's time that
this case got some
better public attention due to i mean
we're not solving it we need to at least
try to involve the public and let them
know
we're we're still working the case and
and uh we could use some help
so
you know a few weeks after that meeting
michelle called me up out of the blue
you know i was you know driving in my
you know unmarked ford taurus i pull
into a parking lot and i'm just you know
sort of in that joe friday mode right i
don't want to you know she's she's a
media person i don't want to you know
play my cards too openly um but i also
because task force we all agreed to
cooperate i wanted to at least be able
to
you know provide her with some
information but when i would give her
very clipped answers to her questions
she would call me on it she would go ah
hold on and she had knowledge about the
case and i was like okay you're right
you know yeah i let me let me kind of
explain a little bit you know where i'm
coming from
you know
from that point on we
kind of stayed in communication as she
was writing this article for los angeles
magazine and developed a little bit of a
bond where at some point i could see she
was really going down a road with with
the slant she was taken
on the articles like well that's not
going to be entirely accurate and i was
debating well should i at least
fill her in in terms of how i'm
proceeding with my investigation
and some of the sensitive aspects i was
dealing with and finally you know i
decided well i'm gonna i'm gonna take a
shot and so i confided in her
um and i let her know this is what i'm
doing this is who i'm looking at this is
the reason why i'm pursuing this
particular route
and
i didn't know how that was going to play
out my big fear when that article came
out was she was going to burn me and
then
you know minimally the task force
members would ostracize me because i was
too open
and then of course i was concerned about
what my own department would do to me
for possibly
compromising an investigation with a
public civilian
journalist
her article came out i read the article
was like
scared as to what i was going to see and
i saw that she didn't burn me
and that's when i was like okay this is
somebody i could trust
and then eventually a few months after
that she had been
asked to write a book about the case
and she called me up and i offered hey
why don't you come up and i will show
you
some of the crime scene locations up
here
and that's what she did and so we spent
12 hours together driving around or
sitting in my office
she's recording the conversations but we
got to know each other and it wasn't
just about the case but we got into know
personal stuff and and we really
developed we bonded we just hit it off
um and then from that point on i was
wide open with her you know this is what
i'm doing this is who i'm pursuing uh
she and her researcher this paul haynes
had some skill sets in the public arena
in terms of getting data that would blow
me away in terms of what they could find
and of course they're kind of looking at
the case and they're hitting me up and
so if they had somebody they said hey we
ran across this name i'd go okay let me
take a look at this person and go up i
can eliminate this person they're in
custody for some of the cases you know
doing this kind of
back and forth assistance um
and and the reality is is over the
course of the next three years michelle
and i became investigative partners you
know we just didn't ride in the car
together but we worked the case together
and we had the highs and lows you know
we both at different times thought we
had solved the case and then dna would
come back and we both found ourselves
crushed
knowing that oh the person we were sure
was the golden state killer was not the
case and it was a unusual
you know public private type of
partnership for an investigation
but on a 44 year old case you know at
some point you go okay
we need i need you know assistance i did
not have a a partner in the case i had a
task force you know but we just kind of
helped each other sporadically we were
spread across the state michelle and i
were very much every night just
communicating whether it be on the case
what we're trying to do how we could
help each other or just commiserating
with each other with whatever was going
on in our personal lives
now that and that is such a rarity
to have somebody you know working a case
whether it's a cold case or obviously
something you know that's just recently
happened and literally have a
partnership not just as someone in the
civilian world but somebody that's in
the media world
uh i mean that is a very very unique
deal so kudos to you though for i guess
not having the ego or you know whatever
it is to thing no this is mine i've got
this i'm gonna you know keep it to
myself because you and i both know
there's a lot of people in this
profession uh and they they hold
everything into themselves and and live
or die by whatever they find
yeah you know and and it's it's it's ego
but also you know like with the media
side i i've been burned by the media you
know i've had i've been interviewed and
i've i've seen how they twist you know
they you know take us an answer out of
context you know and i was like no
that's not that's not what i was talking
about but with michelle you know i it
was just one of those
you know fortunate her her personality
you know really and and the trust she
built with me we just clicked and she
quite frankly she you know developed you
know bonds with other investigators on
the task force she just had a very
um
she was very smart but she also just had
a really easy going personality
that was likable and and she took
advantage of that but she didn't take
advantage of that
well hey well paul listen we've got
about 15 minutes and we still have been
wrapped up uh we're going to
kill her
but we've got a little partner ourselves
so you started or i'm sorry this case
started back in the 1970s as we talked
about and back in the 1970s uh
bodygrooming was a little bit different
than it is these days and that's why we
are happy to partner up with manscape
because we are we are modern gentlemen
here modern and uh in some ways i guess
but we are happy to partner up with
manscaped it is that time of the year
it's hot as hell here in oklahoma it's
104 i've got the the hair cut down right
now howard's kind of cut down as well
you got to stay groomed on the other
parts of your body though right
absolutely man and the thing that's most
important about that is not only do you
have to
stay groomed but it's got to be safe it
does it has to be safe and that's why
the manscape 4.0 you like this paw yeah
the manscape 4.0 if you don't know this
but if i mean if you don't own this
shame on you first of all i know you're
living in colorado now kind of a hippie
area out there yeah you need one you
still need one of these things out there
man the manscape 4.0 if you go to
manscape and use stixx 20 sti cks 20 for
20 off hey and don't forget the ball
deodorizer the ball deodorizer yeah i
didn't even know this was a hygiene
thing that i didn't even know about
until manscape introduced into our lives
and it's like deodorant for your scrotum
yeah would recommend five stars yeah
and i just want to go on record and say
my personal hygiene is on point
thank you absolutely as it should be so
i know you've got
someone else from your your your side
that is listening in right now and i'm
glad that they are muted let's put it
that way
but anyway so uh so d'angelo as you
mentioned you know uh he was in law
enforcement was a police officer what
agency did he work for
i'm going to make this multiple question
what and i i don't know the answer to
that because i did not look that up but
what agency did he work for how long was
he in do we have any idea why he stopped
committing crimes in the 80s that he did
and how did you catch his ass well you
know considering i think you mentioned
earlier you're a criminal justice major
once upon a time back yeah yeah yeah
prior to law enforcement yes yes i was
so easy easy to
very easy to agree by the way if
anybody's listening you want an easy
four-year degree criminal justice is
pretty easy but going fire safety yes so
but deangelo graduated sacramento state
with a criminal justice degree
he uh worked as a roseville pd intern
he was hired by exeter pd which is down
in south central california right next
to visalia that becomes important in
this case and and goes to the police
academy at the college of the sequoias
in visalia
graduates and then is working as an
exeter pd cop
at the same time he's down there this is
when we have a whole bunch of fetish
burglaries going on in the neighboring
town visalia
by an offender known as the visalia
ransacker and at one point when this
visalia ransacker tries to abduct a
16-year-old girl out of her house and
dad tries to come to the rescue he
shoots and kills the dad claude snelling
no shit
well this is deangelo he is an exeter pd
cop at the time these crimes are
occurring he ultimately is promoted at
to a sergeant with exeter
he is part of the burglary the
anti-burglary task force
is sent on the public dime to go to
burglary school where he learns how to
investigate burglaries and how burglars
commit crimes
and then after he gets and shoots is
confronted by an officer when he's got
you know he's he's uh you know
prowling alton visalia
uh deangelo ends up uh
moving up
north of sacramento and becomes an
auburn pd cop he ends he gets the hell
out of dodge
and ends up becoming a patrol officer
with auburn pd and that's
at the time that june of 76
when we start getting the east area
rapist attacks and deangelo as a
full-time auburn police officer
commits 50 sexual assaults or attempted
sexual assaults all over northern
california for the next three years
and the only reason he doesn't stay in
law enforcement is he gets arrested up
in the sacramento area citrus heights
he's trying to shoplift dog repellent
and a hammer out of a convenience store
and now
he's an arrested officer the auburn pd
chief nick willick puts him on admin
leave
and when they go and search his house
they find all sorts of stolen commercial
property like commercial power tools
still in the boxes so he's
he's you know committing commercial
burglaries
in addition to all these east area
rapist attacks but ultimately he is
terminated as an officer
and it's right then when he's terminated
as an officer is when he goes down south
and starts killing
so you look at him the profile his
entire adult life was
being in law enforcement he wanted that
authority he wanted that power and
control over people yet he's committing
these horrendous acts and when he loses
that law enforcement aspect
he escalates to homicide that stressor
was too much he he could not stand
losing
that authority over other people's that
that the badge allowed
and and i believe he continued working
as a security guard though i don't have
any
actual proof i have some circumstantial
evidence and some witness statements
from family members
what speaking of family members was he
married
at all
yeah you know he was uh he got married
1973
um and uh
they were married during the entirety of
the east area rapist phase
as well as the original night stalker
series so
the information i've got is that they
live separately at different points in
their life
um
and the interesting aspect is in 1981 uh
goes in and commits a double homicide in
santa barbara of gregory
sanchez and sherry domingo
and then he doesn't attack again for
five years well it turns out that in
that 1981 case his wife was seven months
pregnant with his first daughter
five years go by that's when he commits
his last attack on janelle cruz in 1986
and that is when his wife is seven
months pregnant with his second daughter
so now after his last known case he's
got two
very young girls in the house and then
he ultimately has a third daughter and
he has no more attacks after this family
gets started now i i can't say that's
why he stopped i mean he was older in
1986 he's 41 years old you know and he
the type of crimes he was committing
were very physically demanding jumping
fences and breaking into houses in the
middle of the night and i believe that
he probably realized that his physical
skill sets physical capabilities were
diminishing
um
well he's clearly not built like the
three of us now that's right that's
right
i mean come on now we're not young but
we can still hop a fence heck yeah i
might be able to get over it but i would
approach it afterwards
well let me ask you what's the
correlation in solving this crime
between the church of latter-day saints
and genealogy this is some interesting
science as well correct
yeah you know well
yeah i i have been pursuing the
genealogy side from dna because you know
when i
eliminated my railroad guy was like what
evidence do i have that i think will
point me in the right direction well i
had this hand-drawn map well that was a
big fail at least at this point in time
but also the dna and we had exhausted
everything about the dna from a
technology standpoint it had been up in
coda's we had searched interpol you know
other countries databases
uh we had done everything we possibly
could with no luck and then it was like
well let's look at genealogy let's see
if we can find his relatives and i
started back that back in 2012
talking with a genetic genealogist by
the name of colleen fitzpatrick who is
still very active and successful to this
day
um but that didn't that older genealogy
technique didn't work out and then i was
involved in another case in which a
different newer version of the genealogy
tool was utilized that helped identify a
little girl as an abducted girl out of
out of new hampshire
i was like how did that work and that's
when i reached out to another
genealogist who had done the work
barbara ray venter and
asked her could this tool
genealogy tool be used to solve you know
identify an unknown offender if we had
his dna because
the golden state killer left his semen
all over california you know he
he wore a mask he always had gloves on
but
you know his semen was everywhere and so
we had his dna and barbara's response
was well i see no reason why it wouldn't
work but then she kind of disappeared
she wasn't communicating and i thought
oh here's a genealogist that doesn't
work with law enforcement but
fortunately i had an fbi guy who was he
was an attorney with the fbi
steve kramer called me out of the blue
and say hey i hear what you're doing
with genealogy because i had given an
update to the task force
and he said how can i help
and then at that point kramer and i
we did a deep dive ourselves in terms of
trying to figure out how this genealogy
tool would work and then how we could
get dna from the southern california
agencies that still had golden state
killer dna
and search the databases and that's what
we
ended up
doing and then barbara came back
six seven months later saying hey do you
still
need my help
yes
absolutely and at this point we had
formed a very small team and due to some
politics which i
discuss in the book out of orange county
we had gone covert with the fear that we
would be shut down
and so i had a small team and we worked
this
and then ultimately
landed on d'angelo and i know
i was skeptical i was looking at
deangelo's background going how could a
full-time
auburn pd officer commit all the crimes
he was doing
across all northern california i was
like there's just no way you know that
he wouldn't have the time
but
decided i better dig into him
well listen uh paul we've only got i
don't know three minutes or so left and
obviously you've got the book up there
behind you unmasked unmasked uh my life
solving america's
cold looks like what was it cold cases
the lights on it's like trying to read
it from here uh but tell us you know
tell us about the book obviously go into
further detail not only about d'angelo
but i assume some other cases
um and you know some of the guys that
we're just not gonna have time because
i know you're very good at this and you
do
uh audiences that want to come listen to
you speak at some of the places you do
talk about this stuff but uh daryl kemp
joseph um
donato joseph cordova jr yeah there's
other you know there's other serial
predators that i had you know some
involvement with helping get caught and
or you know sentenced to death out in
california you know my book unmasked uh
really you know started out as it was
going to be a deep dive on the
investigation of the golden state killer
case and you know it still
does have information on the
investigation that has never been made
public before
but it evolved because when i got my
collaborator rob and gabby fisher who
helped write the book uh and she's
getting to know me and i'm talking about
all these other cases i've been involved
with such as lacey peterson and jc
dugard she was like oh my god you know
here's the story
but as we wrote that now working with
the publisher the publisher was going we
need to know more about paul and you
know part of
what i was experiencing and and
reflecting upon my career to robin is
the emotional
outpouring you know there's times when
i'd be talking to robin and i'm just
breaking down i'm crying as i'm talking
to her
and that's when it became apparent i my
book opens up with a psychological break
that i had after i retired not knowing
what was happening to me and when i went
in to see a therapist and was detailing
the types of cases that i was working
going out to
she's going all of these cases are a
form of trauma and i just suppressed
them and now in my 50s
you know
the career from that side is behind me
but all those cases were like a little
nick
and you know one nick by itself isn't
going to cause you much harm but when
you have hundreds of nicks you start
bleeding out and so my book you know it
really turned into of course you've got
the
you know the golden state killer and
these other cases and the stories and
details but it also turned into the m1
my memoir about how working this career
and these types of cases
has an impact and had an impact on me
and has had an impact on
other professionals that people don't
recognize people understand when an
officer gets involved in a shooting
that's a traumatic event for that
officer
but if you're a homicide investigator
responding to a homicide of a young kid
if you're a death investigator if you're
a csi that's spending hours looking at
family photos while there's a family
member dead in front of you this is not
normal stuff and i know you guys can
relate to this and so that really became
an important message about my book and
you know i was validated i had a
a law enforcement buddy uh he's on
another podcast small town dicks this
dave grice who spent 10 years as a child
abuse investigator shit
he read my prologue and he texted me
saying
that hit me hard i so relate and that
was my validation that was like okay
you know it's not just me experiencing
this there are many people
that have you know lived the life
whether it be in law enforcement whether
it be in the medical side that are
experiencing things that
the average person never sees and you
don't recognize that it's necessarily
trauma but it's affecting your
relationships it's affecting i mean you
you know
the bourbon is definitely a a form of
self-medication and so it really became
a fundamental message to get out there
and so that's really my unmask became a
much bigger
all-encompassing aspect about
my career than what i initially thought
it was going to be
no and paul you're you know just kind of
in closing uh i mean you're spot on
there obviously you know howard you know
being in nursing and going back to the
covet stuff you see stuff that people
shouldn't ever see you know those of us
in law enforcement especially if you're
working for a larger agency that has a
lot of violent crime and you know
child type cases rapes things of that
nature
um i i did a speech
last fall back out in october
and
it was in baltimore and one of the
things i actually spoke about was the
impact that this career has on you and
there's a study out there that shows
that a male in the civilian world
compared to a male in law enforcement
their life expectancy life expectancy is
22 years more than somebody in this
profession and that's why it is it's
it's all of those things over a 20 25 30
35 career 35 year career that that build
up on you on the inside and
you know
i came on in 97
in the law enforcement you were
obviously in there before me even just
in my you know the 20 nearly 25 years i
was on it has changed a lot it used to
be you know you didn't talk about it
you're tough and all this type of stuff
now agencies obviously a lot of them
have psychological services um you know
it's encouraged by peers it's encouraged
by supervisors to go out there and you
know talk to people get help stuff like
that so that you're not
um you know internally just beating
yourself up over it yeah but as all of
us all three of us here can really
attest to
you
you can't be tough through this you
can't man through this stuff you can't
just bow up and take it and go this is
you gotta get some help and people it's
real good to hear you say that you got
some help
definitely coming back from covet
assignments after shoveling bodies
you know i had to get help
if if you're in that situation go talk
to somebody plenty of services out there
that can get you
a different mental perspective that's
much needed don't turn to the bottle
don't turn to being unhappy
let's go talk to somebody all right paul
where can people uh find you um where
can they find your book well you know my
book is available
all over the place uh you know
amazon
uh i'm see i'm seeing it in airports
it's so weird to see there but
you know my you know my life solving
america's cold cases
uh people can find me you know i i have
uh you know twitter and instagram
accounts but i'm not a social media guy
i you know
that really is more you know pr stuff
and i'll post a little personal stuff
but i'm excited about a a new podcast
i'm going to be involved with
it's going to it's called buried bones
it's with kate winkler dawson it's about
historic crimes
so stay tuned that's going to be coming
out soon very excited about that and it
will be available wherever you know you
you can get access to your podcast
well paul man we cannot think of a
better
guest person investigator to close out
uh the cocktails and cocktails to send
yes sunset so brother we appreciate it
man thank you for everything all right
cheers i am so honored to be your last
guest and i
wish you guys the best moving forward
and stay safe
all right now i know you're gonna log on
to manscape have a good one yeah
[Music]